[Musique]
il
de son côté à l'éco design pire poursuit
sa formation d'ébéniste anti gaspi et il
est très motivé alors c'est quoi la
première étape on va faire feu de tout
bois
la première à terme est de découper les
morceaux ok sur la palette avec une
petite six auteurs c'est facile facile
oui pour les esprits bricoleur hors
pierre est plutôt littéraire super ok
donc là tu vas voir c'est très simple
pour avoir les pièces du milieu fait
jouer pour fabriquer cette caisse est
ressenti une baisse historique classique
aurait utilisé du peuplier de culture
soit un arbre de moins dans la forêt de
la balle à découper et raboté elle est
comme ça tu vois on retrouve des clous
plier cloud donc avait prête être à 100
m être tentés et assembler hockey
non content de préserver les forêts du
drame de l'abattage l'éco design
fonctionne aussi par une mécanique dans
bausch solidaire ici tous les ouvriers
sont issus des chantiers d'insertion et
fonctionne plus qu'en équipe
l'éco design c'est une famille c'est
quoi toi ton histoire antonio au moins
bas moi j'étais vous le vendeur de
fruits et légumes pendant beaucoup
beaucoup d'années et ensuite par
l'intermédiaire de pôle emploi et
un plan européen ils m'ont fait
découvrir les chantiers d'insertion
donc là ça permet de re de le redémarrer
bien surtout pas oublier les côtés voilà
déjà qui oblige le côté s'est embrouillé
antonio travaille ici depuis six mois le
passage à l'éco design lui servira de
tremplin pour une reconversion et comme
frédéric chanter il prend son travail
très à coeur ok s'arrête dans ce sens là
hop et là tu peux dessus on a centre en
enlaçant trop j'ai fini ma caisse pop
art déco d'intérieur
regardez comme elle est canon vient d'en
bas on va aller livrer ça on va essayer
d'aller faire des heureux avec cette
pièce c'est parti
[Musique]